he could do two things that would get me
to sing his praises and actually be like
a real supporter okay right
he could stop arming the saudis right he
could stop he could do that
and he can pardon julian assange there
you go he definitely it's a partner i
think he's got a pardon assange
you know what that could be his legacy
honestly if he
did you know on the one hand i think he
could but then on the other hand i'm
like but what's in it for him yeah well
a lot of people oh
well let's let's let's let's do this
story let's read this one this is from
just the other day check this out
trump plots mass pardons even to people
not asking okay axio axios reports
president trump isn't just accepting
pardon requests but
blindly discussing them quote like
christmas gifts to people who haven't
even asked
sources with direct knowledge of the
conversation told axios now i don't know
who their sources are nor do i trust
them for the most part but let's keep
reading
behind the scenes trump recently told
one advisor he was going to pardon
every person who ever talked to me
suggesting an even larger pardon blitz
to come
as with most trump conversations the
advisor wasn't sure how seriously to
take the president
although trump gave no indication he was
joking the president relishes his
unilateral authority to issue get out of
jail free cards lately
lately though he's been soliciting
recipients asking friends and advisors
who they think he should pardon julian
assange
trump has also interrupted conversations
to spontaneously suggest
that he uh that he add the person he's
speaking with
to his pardon list the offers haven't
always been welcome
one source felt awkward because the
president was clearly trying to be
helpful
but the advisor didn't believe they'd
committed any crimes
the advisor also believed being on the
list could hurt their public persona
the white house declined to comment
comment trump argues
the preemptive pardons may be necessary
because the biden administration will
target his former aides the sources say
president-elect biden has said he
doesn't want to pursue the trump team
and he has vowed an apolitical justice
department as axios first reported
trump's decision to pardon michael
flynn's at the template for a wave of
pardons to friends and loyalists
one senior administration official said
the practice has since expanded with
pardons being discussed like christmas
gifts
the white house pardon system doesn't
entirely consist of the president's free
wheeling offers
whitis attorneys are working through a
more traditional process
even if it doesn't cover every person
that trump has discussed a source
familiar with the process says
i'll tell you what i want trump to
pardon almost everybody
yeah non-violent drug offenders yes we
need to review because
uh people in the in the chat made a
really really good point when we first
asked this
there could be people who are violent
who pled down pleaded down to like
lesser charges yes
so there could be like a murderer you
know so uh but non-violent drug offenses
trump should just be like give me a
rubber stamp
and i will just go boom boom boom boom
julian assange of course
i think um my my view on julian
assange's partner 100 do it
my view on edward snowden's pardon is
like 55
well you know look and i can sit here
and we can debate about snowden but he's
his life is not in jeopardy right now
he's not somebody that i
spend time i don't worry like at night
about edward snowden he's in a decent
place like
physically you know whatever and assange
is
he's he's in serious i it's you know
what how do we
like i almost feel like i want i wish i
could like reach out to tucker carlson
and be like please tell trump to pardon
julian assange like
how do we get trump to think that not
only it's my idea it's my brilliant idea
but that it is the best way to stick it
to the establishment dems because it is
well it's difficult because there are
some fingerprints highlighting how
donald trump is partly responsible for
putting assange in the position that
he is and now especially with the
supposed deal that everyone's talking
about as well but i say pardon assange
pardon snowden pardon ross olbert i can
mention a whole bunch of other people i
say pardon
because this leaves the next incoming
presidency in a very peculiar spot
if i was donald trump right now you have
an amazing opportunity bring all the
troops home declassify all the horrible
government studies
they conducted on our population the jfk
files he's been promising to release the
jfk files
for a very long time and he still hasn't
been able to release that's jfk files
for over 60 years ago he keeps getting
blocked okay i mean you have to realize
at some point you're a little bit of an
apologist for him
well i i i don't think the president is
powerful as people think he is
no he's definitely not and we have seen
that we've seen a resurgence of
executive authority in the past two
administrations more so than we should
be seeing because quite honestly the
entire authorization for this military
force shouldn't even exist
yeah so he he's still in more of a power
position
than i think that people know but yet
yeah no he's still accountable to the
same people that everyone's accountable
to
but this is the argument but then don't
talk big then don't
don't talk it if you can't walk it
there's been a lot of people sabotaging
him and if you look at all the leaks
that come out of the white house within
his right-hand person or left-hand
person it's just a slurry of weeks the
mainstream media
wouldn't be as popular if it wasn't for
the trump administration so we have to
understand there
is also some internal pressure that's
preventing him from doing a lot of this
stuff so both could be true
but i think whether whatever politician
it is we always need more scrutiny we
always need to push them we never need
to idolize them we always need to
criticize them no matter who they are
yeah so i agree with you
but you know i i think in regards to the
apologist thing
i think there's so much that trump could
have done if it weren't for the machine
that was blocking him at every turn but
wouldn't you say that about obama
wouldn't you say that about but it's
it's when you have
whoever the president is seems to always
be facing an uphill battle with the
other
um branches and that's by design because
they don't want to do anything so
so the biggest issues with trump are
he's
of bad moral character for the most part
that's like the biggest complaints i
guess people have
yeah uh you can disagree with some of
his politic policy positions for sure
but
obama got us involved in new wars oh no
don't please i regret that
i can't even begin telling him i am not
singing praises establishment
the establishment and mainstream media
loved obama compare the treatment of how
the media is treated
because the media is very neoliberal
that's just the way it is they just are
who they are
you know george w bush i thought was
awful barack obama
i was super excited for voted for and
then immediately got angry and didn't
vote again
and hillary clinton i left and i didn't
want to vote for trump because i'm like
it's all the same
and now i see trump is he made a ton of
mistakes in his first few years
he hired a bunch of really bad people he
should have fired a ton of people
and boy did he walk face first like
sideshow bob into a bunch of rakes
with like you know sessions with you
know not firing comey soon enough and
then getting
special prosecutors there's a whole
bunch of things you know in the mix like
you know i want to bring up
in heavy nuance but trump made a ton of
mistakes he did not realize what this
machine was and i think he thought
he'd be the boss but i look i you know
the president is constrained it's a
political game and you know you've got
to navigate that properly
but i think i think donald trump's a
populist i think he wants to be a
populist i think he
campaigned as a populist but i think
that this he is to me a very good
example
of exactly what you were just saying
where he expected to be the boss
this is the problem when you take
somebody who's a business person and
just think that they're automatically
going to translate into
the political arena it doesn't work um
and and you can't have it my way or the
highway and as we've seen he hasn't been
been able to be effective that way but
he is not the kind of person
i think that is going to have enough
self-reflection to look at that and be
like
what can i do differently like where
could i make better choices he's not
he's a blamer
and i'm not saying the other side
doesn't do it too because they do i mean
but that's ultimately what this comes
down to is he is a very big ego and very
thin skin
i agree and that's a not a good position
to be in as somebody in politics and
that's very easy to manipulate if you're
a special power
he could he could have quickly pivoted
and and corrected a bunch of these
errors very early on
and he didn't well let me be clear
though that i hold barack obama
accountable for a lot of these things
because had he done his job people like
gina haspel would be in prison
and they wouldn't be able to and and
bolton
and so you you have a lot of people that
wouldn't have been able to
do the damage that they did but but
barack obama
barack obama drone bomber drone bomber
obama he's part of the machine
oh yeah so i i don't i don't he i don't
think he wanted to do
no but but again even let's say that he
did
let's say that he said i'm going to do
that i'm going to stand up to you know
what is essentially the military complex
because that's what you really have to
stand up to
he can't do that any more than trump can
do that yeah and that's what we're
looking at we're looking at to some
extent it's really a figurehead position
and you don't have
as much power as you would like but you
have just enough so that you get blamed
for all your incompetence
that's the whole nature of being
president what if trump just like
literally pardoned everybody
at the federal level because it would be
massive whether or not
it would you know salvage him in terms
of like his name in history i don't know
it would for me honestly i'm telling you
the two things that could say if he if
he stopped playing in the sandbox of
saudi arabia
um and or pardoned julian assange that
would
that would be huge for me like that
would be a deal changer for me
i i uh had been saying earlier in the
year that uh
like in january before covet like i
wasn't going to vote for him i don't
care
like that's not that's not my my tribe
i'm not a tribalism but
the the cove it locked down stuff has
been draconian and insane it's it's been
transferring it's the biggest transfer
of wealth from working-class people to
the elites the establishment to the big
corporations
that's insane and and it's and and you
get the establishment
what do you what do you call these
people like you know
i i call them the democrats i guess well
see no no i need to know exactly who
you're talking about and then i can i
know
the exact terminology so we're speaking
the people who work at the new york
times
who are like we must lock everything
down and they're ultra neoliberal drones
those are or tools i mean those are
tools that's an option
yeah neil is but see that's what people
really need to understand that is not
the left
the democrats are not the left that's
not the left the democrats at best are
centrists
i think i think you know what really you
know what just confused me is why
leftists were so anti-trump when i
understand you cannot like trump but
he's
anti-establishment yeah again which
leftists like i have never been
anti-trump again for me it's all policy
it's all policy
so it's never been anything like that
and i am not the only one there are
others like me we're out there
um the establishment doesn't like him
because he offends their sensibilities
i don't care about that i don't care who
he makes fun of
i don't care what he says i don't care
who he sleeps with i don't care what his
children do i really don't think this
doesn't concern me
what concerns me is his policy and the
policies of the republican party do not
appeal to me
that's just that they just don't they're
they don't have populist
policies even though he intended that
yeah the the republican party i've never
been a fan of
i think i think trump i think trump's
very different i mean trump supporters
use a lion instead of an elephant
but i think trump that's funny so do the
progressives there's a lion yeah
in fact our our progressive caucus in
broward county our symbol is a lion
really you know i kind of wondered if
biden would actually end up being the
great
uniter because by default because
everyone hates him
well he's just except for the neolithics
yeah he's they are a small group
unfortunately they're loud
and they have the media other than fox i
mean you know but
really other than fox you've got a whole
bunch of neolib
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time